Even the most intense and dramatic movies
can’t keep actors from goofing around, which
means plenty of blooper reels and blown takes
for fans to enjoy during the credits, or as
a bonus on home video.
But sometimes, a spur-of-the-moment decision,
mistake, or even injury can be too good to
cut.
Make sure you comment below as you watch!
We want to know what you guys think!
Here are ScreenRant’s 10 Movie Bloopers
That Made It To The Final Cut.
Django Unchained
Quentin Tarantino’s western was one only
a few movies to put Leonardo DiCaprio in a
supporting role, but the actor found a surprising
way to prove he’s always a superstar.
During the movie’s climactic dinner scene,
Calvin Candie’s anger explodes in smashed
bone, glass – and blood.
The injury was completely unplanned, with
the other actors clearly stunned as the director
and actor kept on rolling.
You can even watch as DiCaprio picks the glass
from his hand once his speech is over.
Hopefully, the blood smeared on his co-star
wasn’t quite as real.
Mission Impossible 2
When filming the final fight in Mission: Impossible
2, Tom Cruise and a stuntman trained to make
their moves as realistic as possible – including
swinging a knife just millimetres from his
eye.
But when his fellow stuntman told Cruise not
to pull back on his final kick, he didn’t
– planting his foot squarely on his partner’s
jaw.
Director John Woo used the entire shot, including
the star’s clearly shocked reaction to his
mistake.
Zoolander
Ben Stiller’s world famous male model is
better known for his looks than his smarts,
but one joke concerning Derek’s low IQ rose
above the rest.
When David Duchovny’s character explains
why male models make the perfect brainwashed
assassins, Derek doesn’t quite keep up.
The moment wasn’t planned.
Stiller simply forgot his next line, and instead
of ruining the take, repeated the question.
Duchovny didn’t miss a beat, giving as deadpan
a response as he could, delivering one of
the more memorable jokes in the process.
Knocked Up
Stars Seth Rogen, Jason Siegel Jonah Hill,
and Jay Baruchel open the movie with a montage
of wasting time, capping the scene off with
a ride on a spinning roller coaster.
A ride not ALL of them enjoyed.
Baruchel’s fear of roller coasters was so
strong, he agreed to appear naked in the movie
just to avoid the ride.
But the director and cast pushed him to do
it, meaning Siegel had to appear in the flesh,
and Baruchel’s genuine terror made it into
the movie.
Raiders of the Lost Ark
When Indiana Jones attempts to ambush a group
of Nazis with his leading lady held prisoner,
the movie’s villain Belloq takes part in
a surprise cameo.
A fly suddenly appearing on an actor’s face
can usually ruin a take, but the bug disappearing
implies something much worse.
According to actor Paul Freeman, the effects
team thought it would be funnier to erase
the fly’s escape, turning what could have
been a blown take into an infamous moment
that’s impossible to miss.
Midnight Cowboy
Quite possibly the most famous blooper in
movie history, Ratso Rizzo’s catchphrase
in Midnight Cowboy was completely unplanned.
As the crew secretly filmed actors Dustin
Hoffman and Jon Voight on a New York street,
a taxi nearly hit the pair of them crossing
the street.
The actors maintain it was completely unplanned,
but as Voight watched on in surprise, Hoffman
turned the blown take into not just the most
well-known scene in the movie, but a line
that would become even more well-known and
iconic than he could ever have guessed.
The
Lord of the Rings
When Gandalf first arrives to visit Bilbo
in Bag End, he shows how hard it can be to
move through a miniature home.
Actor Ian McKellen’s fumbling with the chandelier
was planned, but his sudden slam into a ceiling
beam wasn’t.
His surprised shout and laugh were too good
to leave out, and Peter Jackson left the mistake
in the finished film.
Blade Runner
Ridley Scott’s sci-fi detective story made
actress Daryl Hannah an up-and-coming star
overnight, but her dedication to the role
went beyond acting.
When her character is introduced, she panics,
running off and smashing the window of a parked
van.
The stunt wasn’t planned, meaning Hannah
simply slammed into the van with enough force
to shatter the very real glass – and her
elbow along with it.
She remained in character, making sure the
mistake wound up in the original film – and
wound up in surgery herself.
Rain Man
Stars Tom Cruise and Dustin Hoffman were at
the top of their game in this tale of dysfunctional
brothers, but that doesn’t mean some unintended
moments were to thank for one of its most
famous moments.
When the pair are squeezed into a phone booth,
Hoffman’s character takes things from bad
to worse, passing some gas in the cramped
space.
But Hoffman wasn’t making it up, simply
giving his co-star a heads-up on his flatulence.
Cruise took the cue to stay in character,
and the rest is history.
Back to the Future Part 2
The hover boards may have become the runaway
stars of the Back to the Future series, but
the futuristic gadgets also led to one of
the trilogy’s most disastrous stunts.
When Biff’s gang tries to take out Marty
in 2015, they wind up smashing through a courthouse
window.
The risky stunt called for all three actors
to fly through the glass before dropping safely
below, but an error sent stuntwoman Cheryl
Wheeler-Dixon slamming into a pillar instead.
With the timing thrown off, she was dropped
thirty feet onto the stone below.
She survived the fall, but sustained serious
injuries.
Even more shocking?
The stunt was only performed once, meaning
her fall can actually be seen in the finished
film, thankfully cutting away a split second
before impact.
So what do you think of our list?
Did we miss any of your favorite bloopers
or happy accidents that ended up in movies?
Let us know in our comment section and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for more
videos like this one.